en plena hora pico un hombre disparó
contra los pasajeros del metro de nueva
york después de haber arrojado un gas en
el vagón el ataque provocó escenas de
caos en brooklyn
había mucha gente salir de la estación
de tren gritando pidiendo ayuda vi a una
señora que recibió un disparo en la
pierna una de las señoras dijo que era
un tipo con una pistola y que tenía una
máscara y un chaleco y estaba disparando
a la gente vas
los pasajeros bajaron del tren en estado
de confusión
al principio fue un momento de shock
estaba con algunos amigos no sabía qué
iba a pasar tenía miedo no sabía qué
hacer no lo sabía me bajé del tren me
quedé junto a unos policías y espere lo
mejor eso es todo
nueva york- ha visto un aumento en la
tasa de criminalidad desde el inicio de
la pandemia tan sólo en lo ocurrido de
2022 la ciudad ha registrado
260 tiroteos
la gente de todo el estado de nueva york
está con la gente de esta ciudad de esta
comunidad y decimos no más no más
tiroteos masivos no más alteraciones de
la vida no estamos creando angustia para
la gente que solo trata de vivir sus
vidas como neoyorquinos normales eso
tiene que terminar y terminar ahora ya
el ataque tuvo lugar un día después que
el presidente joe biden anunciara nuevas
medidas para controlar el porte de armas
de fuego en el país específicamente
contra las de fabricación casera
conocidas como armas fantasma la medida
que enfrenta la oposición de el poderoso
lobby armamentístico